compte tenu de tout ce qui se passe
autour en termes d'événements et de
nouvelles jupes tout simplement pris la
décision de retourner la partie médicale
ce que j'adore je démissionne en tant
que ministre est légalement tant que je
lui souhaite bonne chance je sais que
d'abord qu'il est un excellent médecin
et les bonnes nouvelles pour plusieurs
patients
merci
alors nous commençons notre table ronde
à québec on s'attendait à ce que le
ministre de l'éducation évoluent soit
rétrogradé il a plutôt pris la décision
de quitter la politique avait-il
vraiment d'autre choix
est ce que c'est la fin aussi des
problèmes du gouvernement où il ya
beaucoup de questions je me disais tâche
à daniel michel bonsoir bonsoir michel
il ya eu quand même beaucoup de bons
mots aujourd'hui à l'endroit de monsieur
bolduc mais ce que c'est pas un peu
inévitable se dit par oui tout à fait
écouter monsieur bolduc est totalement
déconsidéré non seulement dans
l'ensemble d'opinions publiques mais
aussi dans le réseau de l'éducation qui
était non seulement un sujet d'embarras
pour tout gouvernement mais n'était plus
en mesure de gérer son ministère et
encore moins d'initier des réformes
monsieur couillard qui avait déjà eu le
tort de toute évidence d'un homme et l'a
arrêté irresponsable de laisser la plus
longtemps alors c'était inévitable ceci
étant dit son état paul scénario
privilégié par monsieur par monsieur
couillard il aurait certainement aimé
mieux pouvoir attendre jusqu'en juin
pour inclure la d'émotion ou le renvoi
enfin peu importe le sort de monsieur
bolduc dans un remaniement plus large
qu'il va à mon sens de toute manière
avoir lieu en juin
alors daniel comment interpréter ce
geste on se demande toujours un peu si
on démissionne aussi on ait démissionné
comme on dit question est pertinente
écouter à le symbole de tout si elle est
mal chez les libéraux ne secoue ya il
est parti est ce que ça veut dire qu'à
partir de maintenant tout va bien aller
qu'on va retrouver la cohésion à il
faudra voir dans les prochains jours
rien n'est moins certain
est ce qu'on l'a forcé à démissionner
est ce qu il a démissionné de lui-même
écoutez j'ai vu plusieurs cas comme ça
une trentaine d'années de couverture
politique souvent ce premier ministre
qui appelle lumineuse qui vous écoutera
à toute allure
il faut que tu t'en ailles on va trouver
une façon honorable de le faire tu
remettras démission je te dis que tu es
bof un gentil intelligent et puis on
n'en parle plus woods ou dans des cas ou
dans des cas et c'est arrivé très
souvent aussi pour nous mener sans
relâche et demande à son chef de cabinet
rappelle terminé s'est dit lui que c'est
fini on trouve une façon de
mettre fin à son ministère point à la
ligne je sais pas comment ça s'est passé
hier je soupçonne que monsieur un coup
iard et jack qui se connaissent bien qui
ont l'air de bien se met ce sont
sûrement à paris oui je sais monsieur
couillard qui avait nommé donc monsieur
bolduc
quelle est sa part de responsabilité
dans vie du coup il ya michel disais
tout à l'heure c'est quand même lui qui
l'a gardée si longtemps dans ce poste-là
d'achat oui je trouve que la décision ce
qu'on décide à couper c'est mieux de le
faire plus rapidement et après les
propos que les derniers propos que
monsieur bolduc avait fait concernant la
fouille à nu pieds c'était tout le
canada qui en parler je pense était
assez évident que c'était un grand
problème c'est un peu comme le julian
fantino de monsieur jack et à un moment
donné il n'as plus de crédibilité dans
son propre ministère il doit partir moi
je pense que monsieur khouya aurait dû
prendre cette décision plus rapidement
après la dernière transgression mais
prix allemand il a pris on va voir
maintenant qui remplace et comment ça va
aller comme comme pauline marois l'avait
fait par dont michel comme pauline
marois l'avait fait avec daniel pour
autant ça s'était passé assez rapidement
michel donc une part de responsabilité
pour la sucrière oui oui tu es
certainement écouté il voulait faire de
la place au départ gaétan barrette dans
son équipe qui donc ne pouvait pas aller
ailleurs qu'à la santé il a décidé de
donner un prix de consolation et tout un
à monsieur bolduc en allemand à
l'éducation alors la responsabilité
était et elle a arrêté du le monde dort
plus tôt oui sans doute mais vous savez
c'est déjà un record de brièveté la
l'éducation même si les ministres se
succèdent rapidement ce ministère la
depuis depuis 50 ans ma foi
non non c'est passé c'est de moins en
moins facile il ya eu une époque où
c'était souvenez-vous de la révolution
tranquille ça allait bien c'était
glorieux d'être ministre de l'éducation
va beaucoup d'argent donc moi j'ai la
joie et la nouvelle exemple tout à fait
alors que maintenant
on gère la décroissance à ce qui est
beaucoup plus difficile évidemment le
problème aussi c'est que ça on n'a pas
expulsion monsieur bolduc que plus tôt
on lui demande d peut-être de s'en aller
messieurs couillard a punis tous les
ministres c'est sûr qu'il y avait
d'autres propos de madame vers les
autres qui était problématique mais il
ya plus ni tout le monde en les imposant
le silence avant le caucus et les chose
qui vraiment je pensais comme on dit la
semaine passée enfants utiliser tout le
monde s'il aurait il aurait pu sortir
monsieur bolduc lui rapidement peut-être
il aurait évité de faire cela bon il ya
aussi cette prime de cent cinquante cinq
mille dollars
une prime une indemnité de départ à
laquelle il a droit en fait monsieur
bolduc mais amir khadir de québec
solidaire dit aujourd'hui qu'il devrait
la refuser daniel écouté il y as droit
vous l'avez dit vous avez raison il ya
il ya des patrons dans le monde des
affaires qui partent avec des millions
et des millions de dollars est ce que
politicien de partir avec français 35
villes c'est tout à fait légal
elles sont doit blâmer monsieur beaulieu
qu'on doit peut-être bhl avait un
monsieur base de quel parti libéral
russie si je me trompe pas michel
corrige mois si oui quand bernard
drainville a déposé un projet de loi
pour éliminer ce genre de primes là
c'est parti libéral qui a torpillé le
projet doit donc qui n'ont qu'eux à
blâmer
est ce que est ce que monsieur est ce
que monsieur bolduc a répliqué pour les
démissionnaires
est ce que monsieur a boy aurait pu
trouver une façon de le rendre
démissionnaire aussi est ce que monsieur
beauvais lui pour ce beau gère ce geste
élégant disant je renonce à ma prime je
m'en vais ça n'aurait sûrement
réhabilité dans la population il a
choisi de faire autrement voyage mais
service avant embêter le raid
gouvernement tout entier cette histoire
là et monsieur bolduc s'est peut-être
dit ben vous avez voulu me mettre dehors
maintenant après mois le tout se termine
pour lui comme ça avait commencé parce
qu'il est arrivé dans la controverse
avec avec ce sont deux cent mille
dollars comme les nouveaux patients
quand il a l'air un peu mesquin et là
dedans parce que souvenez vous il ya
deux députés un cac et c'est christian
dubé qui est parti à la caisse et qui a
renoncé à son indemnité
même chose pour elsa cueillette du pq
alors lui il ya l'air de vouloir avoir
le beurre l'argent du beurre et il ya un
journaliste d'ap rès quinzaine
aujourd'hui qui a calculé qu en tout et
partout tout bien compté
monsieur bolduc avait touché quelque
chose comme un million de dollars de
deniers publics au cours des deux
dernières années
si on inclut les rémunérations comme
médecin qui est là depuis depuis sept
ans comme député mais quand même ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'il va partir a
nulle part il va devenir médecin il va
avoir un salaire il va avoir un emploi
alors c'est pas comme une certains
politiciens qui n'ont rien quand ils
sont mis dehors ou qu'ils perdent une
élection finalement bon alors qui sera
le successeur de monsieur bolduc vos
suggestions daniel écouter avec ce qui
s'en vient en éducation avec ce qu'on
nous annonce comme chaleur ou froideur
du prêt est en jeu beaucoup de réserves
là-dessus faudra voir mais c'est un
dossier extrêmement compliqué
extrêmement difficile il a besoin d'un
autre gaétan barrette si je t'ai fait
des couilles à prendre un vieux de la
vieille qui a pas peur de ce bart
bagarreur de rue comme pierre paradis où
jean marc fournier
si moi je prendrais plutôt quelqu'un qui
a une connaissance de réseaux monsieur
monsieur fourni effectivement déjà passé
par là pour éteindre un feu mais il
s'est arrangé pour rien faire pendant
deux ans alors y'a rien qui avance et au
ministère de l'éducation
la personne qui a le mieux réussi à mon
sens au cours des dernières années c'est
michelle courchesne
il y la raison était que comme ancien
sous-ministre à connaissait très bien le
fonctionnement de la machine et celui ou
celle je devrais dire plutôt qu'il me
semble avoir la meilleure connaissance
des machines actuellement ses élans
david qui a été à la fois vice rectrice
et sous ministre parce que vous savez
c'est un ministère qui peut facilement
bouffer un nouveau
venus qui connait rien qui se fait
embarquer d'assaut par des pédagogues
ouais mais vous savez ça les avions sont
rapides c'est ainsi ce monsieur couderc
voulait absolument l'a nommé là il y
aurait moyen de trouver une solution
on aura la réponse demain je voudrais
qu'on se déplace à ottawa maintenant
pour parler de ce projet de loi c 51
y at il de la récupération politique
d'achat veut un [ __ ] accusent le
gouvernement de joux de jouer au fond
sur les inquiétudes sur toutes ces
menaces en ce moment pour passer
rapidement son projet voici 51 ce qu'est
l'urgence mais il ya une certaine
urgence je pense dans le sens que le
gouvernement ne veut pas trop scruté à
la loupe le projet de loi c'est vrai
qu'ils ont doublé le nombre
d'intervenants potentiel pour des
experts qui vont parler pas vraiment pas
dans la faveur du projet alors les pda
tout l'intérêt de détendre sud de
détendre ce débat là mais je pense
qu'ils coûtent ces événements le
gouvernement ne crée pas ces événements
là ils ont lieu ici partout on est
toutes sortes de nouvelles les étudiants
à québec par exemple à dernières
nouvelles sur la radicalisation
alors je pense dans le sens du public il
ya une certaine urgence aussi le
gouvernement joue sur ça mais daniel
steven blaney disait aujourd'hui le
projet de loi va permettre d'éradiquer
en amont les personnes susceptibles
d'être radicaliser lundi j'ai appuyé sur
la menace sur le west edmonton mall
c'est pas de la récupération politique
quand même absolument écouter les on est
à quelques mois des élections
et ça risque d'être ce pourrait être le
point principal de la prochaine campagne
électorale le sujet principal en tout
cas le thème favori des conservateurs il
ya beaucoup de récupération des
événements comme ceux de ce matin pleine
page pour nous annoncer que des
cégépiens sont rendus en irak ou en
syrie a qu'une étudiante denton aussi ça
ajoute à la semi panique qui est
installé dans la population surtout
qu'avec beaucoup moins dans le reste du
canada mais surtout au québec et c'est
clair que les conservateurs vont jouer
là dessus c'est clair qu'ils vont faire
beaucoup de récupération politique c'est
un gros vendeur à 82% dans le dernier
sondage zioui allez-y faites tout ce que
vous voulez on va vous suivre si on
faisait un sondage aux gens
d'après les premières pages de ce matin
aux sables est à 90% sylvaner peut
peut-être bien des défauts mais il sait
comment joue la joute politique et ça va
pas régler tous les problèmes quand même
ce projet de loi michel banon évidemment
mais je connais pas beaucoup de projets
de loi qui réussissent à régler tous les
problèmes savoir d'ailleurs ça peut même
en créer des nouveaux je comprends les
conservateurs de vouloir limiter le
nombre d'experts qui vont qui vont
témoigner là dessus parce qu'il ya
certainement des inquiétudes à y avoir
du côté des libertés fondamentales de la
vie privée mais l'objectif là
honnêtement les poteaux demande de
régler les problèmes que de 200 da
l'élection avec le maximum de capital
politique possible j'aimerais qu'on
parle aussi de ce cette décision de
stephen harper de contester un jugement
la cour ontarienne sur le micam un
jugement qui disait qu'une personne
pouvait être assez mal pouvait être
assermenté avec avec le visage couvert
tâche est ce qu'il faut s'étonner que
stephen harper aille à l'encontre de ce
jugement
ils n'ont absolument pas écoute je pense
que même si la cour a raison
techniquement dans la loi ces permis
d'avoir fuller devant son visage si on
le veut à une cérémonie
je pense que ça frustre que beaucoup de
gens et monsieur rappaz y compris je
pense que monsieur harper pour lui c'est
une question de principe disant que
quand vous devenez le citoyen de nouveau
payé vous
vous plier à certaines coutumes mais
vous respectez le fait qu'on veut voir
votre visage à une cérémonie de
citoyenneté même si ce n'est pas écrit
dans les modalités de cette cérémonie
c'est quelque chose des gens attendent
que l'on vous voit alors je pense que
oui c'est sûr que ça s'appelait
certaines portions de la base
conservatrice mais je pense ça touche
aussi beaucoup de canadiens dans le
climat où on vit qui disent que nos
valeurs sont menacés alors bonne
stratégie les libéraux et le npd vont à
l'encontre du gouvernement
daniel mathieu pas dans le cas des
libéraux probablement oui parce que bon
justin trudeau a beaucoup appuyé le
gouvernement sur toutes ces questions là
doit trouver des façons de se démarquer
des droits individuels sont c'est
important pour le parti libéral je suis
sûr que des des vieux libéro à la loi et
à exploiter à l'agent un chrétien qui
lui audi un instant là ne va pas trop
loin
il ya des démarches qui ne faut pas
dépasser 60 et une dans le casual pdc
beaucoup plus compliqué je suis pas
certain que thomas mulcair lui même est
très à l'aise avec cette décision là
mais il ya une vieille garde très
important très influente avec les aime
voir dans tes plusieurs essentielle néo
démocrate stephen lewis kiwi pour eux
c'était absolument la décision de
stephen harper facilement un anathème
inacceptable et c'est à moi me tarde pas
eu le choix que de se plier à ses
diktats
il nous reste pas beaucoup de temps mais
j'aimerais juste que vous montrez quand
même cette publicité du bloc québécois
qui attaque justement le npd sur cette
position là on pourrait peut-être la
voir à l'écran c'est la voie la faute il
ce qu'il faut que se cacher le visage
pour voter npd
alors évidemment on comprend le voile et
comment on voit le parlement michel est
ce que qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ben je pense que sur le fond
le le bloc et le gouvernement peut
d'ailleurs sont au diapason de l'opinion
au québec et pour le bloc l'ennemi
numéro 1 la prochaine élection ça va
être le npd alors sur le fond je pense
que c est limite sur le bon cheval
la forme maintenant ce que j'aime pas
dans cette danse est publiée il ya une
forme de malhonnêteté intellectuelle
ça veut dire qu' on essaie d'associer
dans le fond le npd à l'intégrisme et ça
c'est pas c'est pas la vraie raison de
blocs se pose à ça dans le fond parce
que ça reflète le multiculturalisme et
c'est pour ça que la publicité 13 du bon
malheureusement c'est tout le temps
qu'on a mais quand même je voulais le
mentionner alors merci beaucoup à vous
trois à cinq prochaines revoir